[Music]
holy hell
lizzo fat James cat three of lizzo's
former dancers have accused her of
sexual harassment creating a hostile
work environment and body shaming they
said they've pressured her to touch a
new performer at a club in Amsterdam
have you ever have I ever put you in
that kind of awkward position
no you've never pressured me to touch a
nude performer in Amsterdam thank you
thank you thank you very much for that
I think okay who we don't know if this
is true or not or whatever but she
really did a dangerous thing when she
made her whole brand being like I'm the
nice lady and I'm against bullying and
I'm so nice which is why I make sure
that's not my own brand no no no because
I'm actually a very nice person but
nobody would ever guess that so if they
when they see me being nice they're like
wow we didn't expect that I believe this
is a Shakedown emphasis on Shake Walter
have we ever seen lizzo and Tyrus in the
same room together
no I'm claustrophobic
[Applause]
thank God you guys are friends
it's quick
what do you make of this I think it's a
Shakedown no uh listen everyone well we
always say this cat you back me up
everyone should be heard and I read the
whole article looking for something but
is if it's one person but it's several
and the incidents you have the
performers you have the strippers you
have uh shakedowns and phones being come
like one woman was so scared she soiled
herself and then they gave her a
see-through outfit to wear like here's
the thing about you you portray
especially with weight people like to
portray for attention that that's how
they want to be but when the camera's
off they're unhappy they're miserable
they don't like getting looked at she's
wants to be deep down she wants to be
recognized for her talent but she's made
herself a circus spectacle and she's
bitter and of course what do you do you
project and you take it out on the other
the other women around you who look just
like you but you demoralize them to feel
better about yourself lizzo this is uh
this is probably a new my rule is if
it's one you usually you can it could be
a Shakedown or something Shady but in my
opinion when you get numbers coming
forward that's kind of hard to fight off
it so it's interesting to see because
she's so quick to want to cancel
everybody else and go after one else
let's see what happens when they have to
literally eat their own now literally
don't eat your own you guys it's going
to take a long time I believe she
already has oh last word Mikey so yeah
look uh if it turns out to be true I'll
be sad I've got every lizzo eight-track
that she's put out
um I to cat's point I thought it was a
real solid one here which is when you
put yourself out there you know to be
self-righteous and you know really a
good solid person better than everyone
else it's going to come back and bite
you in in your really big ass yeah yes
that's why I have the reputation of
you'll never be disappointed America hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else